do all millionaires think the same today
we find out a millionaire
I can answer finally we're doing a you
believe spectrum spectrum yes which
means I get to play along and you can
silently judge me how about that
self-made has to be somebody that was
growing up broke I disagree with that
you can mow lawns for a few months and
make like a few thousand dollars we know
how many lawns I'm gonna have tomorrow
it's a lot of lawns once they say once
Matalan lot of my limes
that's right poor people you're not
mowing enough lawns I keep telling you
guys you gotta get Mon lowing what are
you doing
cringe Sykes the key to my success is
just working hard like 18 to 20 hour
days every day of my life and having no
life but having a lot of money alright I
don't care who they are I'm sorry
they're all six millionaires with
different values and beliefs I am
self-made hold up hold up hold up
strongly agree somewhat again okay I
would put myself I agree
[Music]
okay so 72% agree growing up I didn't
need anyone in my family that was it was
in real estate I didn't have anyone of
my family that you know had millions of
dollars and for me I'd blame properties
for something fifteen six years I
haven't twenty bucks
and working part-time after school and
like saving away all that money then I
used that money to get my real estate
license I barely graduated high school I
never went to college
two divorced parents so I should not
have become wealth that's right if your
parents divorce you got no chance I know
he's just listing a couple things I get
it but still that sounded kind of dumb
sure you can list things that would make
it easier for you I don't know see
statistically what I believe that I put
in them no one's the sickest no one
statistically is going to make it
statistically most people don't I
literally started from the bottom I'm
not saying that I was ever homeless or
anything but I did grow up in a
single-family house hold everyone's odds
are stacked against you shut up
administration my counselor told me I
would never make it in business so it's
self-pitying to go like I should not
have been successful guys
everything was against me I just had to
am i being crude maybe a little bit I
just generally think people becoming
rich is such a fluke that I don't that
doesn't mean they didn't work for it but
it's so much luck involved in it so to
act it's like somewhat self-important or
about it it just I don't know I feel
weird about it
I'm somebody that was growing up broke
in my opinion like you got it from the
bottom and I didn't get it from the
bottom I just grew that I don't think no
I agree with her actually I totally
agree with a you need to come from
straight from the bottom like I started
with a few thousand dollars I know a lot
of people who started I got a small loan
of a million dollars it was very tough
for me what do you mean up thousand
that's a ton like if you had nothing at
that was a dollar so that's a huge
advantage are you kidding me yes yes it
matters like your life like you can't
the zero but let's say you start with a
thousand dollars I still believe
yourself maybe even ten thousand even
twenty thousand because you're not truly
like a even six figures or seven figures
I'm broke and I live at Mom's house with
zero dollars you're in a way better you
can vote yes you are oh my god does he
not see it you can mold lines here at
every few months it makes like a few
thousand dollars like there's we know
how many lawns I'm gonna have tomorrow
it's a lot of lawns but that is
self-made the point was hot how much do
you feel like you're self-made and if
you start off with money given to you
that's that's obviously an advantage I
would have been better off if I had
money in the beginning that would help
tremendously oh oh all right let's see
where I would put myself I would put
somewhat agree maybe it's a piss people
off I don't know I I just remember being
it the the reason some ways is for a
short time it was a short time I was
very very poor and I was too proud to
ask my parents for money and I could
barely afford buying food I'm sure most
people gone through this at some point
in their life worth you can't really
afford food you just buy I remember just
buying pasta and just living that off
for a month and I would eat it plain
with some spices and that was
because I was all I could afford but it
wasn't a long time period in my life
it's not like I grew up being poor or
whatever did they just they did they
just high five not being poor let me see
that again
yeah not being poor gang man being poor
and being broke I've been broke before
like me my husband I've been broke many
times in like our relationship but we've
never been poor and even like a long
time ago when I lived in a one-bedroom
apartment with my family we were never
poor I mean I was happy like I had
pudding we went to like parks and stuff
I never felt poor damn she had pudding
all I had was spaghetti you don't
understand my struggles well I got
kicked out and moved into my
grandparents garage and so I was poor
mentally and I was broke financially and
I had to take care of myself at a very
young age so for a decade I was running
a pool company in order to eventually
gain the opportunities to ultimately
move that ball down the court obviously
so but were you happy I mean I wasn't
what the hell why are you happy he said
he was poor financially or mentally as
well like not really right because there
was a lot of stuff going on and like I'm
living in a garage and I'm growing up
and I had to not only he didn't have
pudding I think that's the issue here no
pudding I had to bust my ass off to help
my mom so for me I feel like we all
start from somewhere we go through
certain motions because it builds
character I like that I'm jealous of you
guys I wish I had that mindset like I
traveled to third world countries to
kind of this guy wish he could mow lawns
that's really it I grew up really really
great but then I hit 20 and I moved out
with some boy in the situation got very
very domestic violence you know I was
living in a penthouse and I'm sorry I
got too much pride I wasn't gonna go
back home and you know I'm like black
and blue like getting locked in like
closets like really really toxic stuff
so that for me was very very poor now
did it sling I mean that's obviously
awful but what does that have to do with
being poor I'm so confused shot me too
six-figure a month income
yes but in that state of mind and in
that environment I felt like I was
really poor like I looked beat-up and my
direct deposit was not gonna fix a black
eye you know like oh no no oh god I
don't want to pay more taxes god damn I
look so red what is happening I need to
stop shooting so late at night what the
hell I look insane dude there must be
something going on here why is it so
dark there's no way there must be
something on my camera settings all
right guys this is how it looks night
now
I'm sorry guys I'll get it fixed next
video oh thank god oh thank god I
thought I would be the only ones oh no
like you know you make more money you
obviously do have to pay somewhat more
no feel like we deserve extra things to
pay just because we have more money like
we shouldn't be looked to as like a fun
you know from the government or someone
else who just feels like oh you have
more money you should pay more in taxes
I just feel like it should be a little
bit more freedom with it cuz it's really
really stressful and I feel like a lot
of businesses fail in the first three
years because a tax is not because
they're bad at business not because
they're about it managing money but
because they're not prepared to do
everything by the book true true I don't
mind paying taxes
obviously obviously I just wish I knew
where they were going big companies who
sell a lot of their services like in the
US and then they have some like Ireland
tax status where they're getting out of
it like Apple and Amazon and these big
companies that theoretically should pay
billions in taxes while it's us average
people who are really supporting the
government I think there should be a
little Aboriginal people and they are
average average men British people
millionaire I see what he's trying to
say though cuz everyone likes to pick on
millionaires and be like more taxes when
in reality these huge companies are
avoiding so much but they
supplying jobs they are supplying a
service I don't know
Amazon paid zero dollars in taxes didn't
didn't Amazon save that because they cut
on on the on bosses they got a tax break
or something like that I don't know
enough about these things
I just know people like to throw out
lines for that knowing the new ones just
like I just stayed you donated $690,000
yeah he makes an average of 200 million
dollars per day yeah I put out a whole
press release and I'm just like come on
dude haha give a little donation shaming
donation shaming you're not donating it
up I see your net worth online you have
to donate more me donate
no I'm not gonna donate you need to
donate more to be fair they have created
a lot of jobs through people I actually
sell on Amazon so through Amazon FBA
he's provided an opportunity for people
like me to make a living for myself to
be able to start a business you know
online and to be able to make internet
money so like to have that freedom and
like whether we think that he needs to
give more or not I mean that's really up
to him what he does with his money I
would put disagree I think the most
expensive thing I own is my car and
that's just like 60,000 just 60,000
listen to me I guess I own properties I
just don't like having things it makes
me feel overwhelmed I'm just like no
stop no more thank you I realize how
spoiler I sound but if you were in my
shoes you would understand is really
tough getting free stuff all the time my
husband my husband is like 90 grand car
and added like a 200 grand car I'm like
why did you do that like you don't need
you don't need to he's like well I mean
I could so why not like I don't want to
pay more in taxes but I don't have to
pay buy more cars but I just did I just
do
I don't want to pay more taxes I mean I
grew up wanting cars like I my whole
bedroom was like plastered with cars on
the wall and then when I could actually
buy it it was like it's so fine right I
was fulfilling a childhood dream it
wasn't even about the car it was the
challenge yes I had all the cars the
thrill was gone so I mean it Hey look at
that he understands he's learning money
just bites you materialistic goods they
just either satisfies a craving or a
momentarily spark of joy that will fade
true happiness we think oh no I think
that you should all have like dreams and
chase those dreams whatever they are
maybe they don't cost that much but I
mean not everything's materialistic like
when I started making money yeah I
changed my body yeah I know I mean
I wouldn't cleared my skin yeah I
wouldn't got a tattoo what I would not
like you know what I mean like yeah
don't get hair extensions like I've
definitely purchased things in the past
that were cool and it was because I
could but as times gone along for me
I've realized so many times that every
time I hit the goal or the destination
of the target I realized that the
journey was so much more fun and and as
I've achieved more success and built
more companies it's almost every time
now where I get there and I'm like man
the journey was actually funner than the
destination yeah right
yeah cause like yeah but the question
was if you've spent an absurd amount of
money just because you can not me mm-hmm
I used to buy a lot of bags I'm like no
I like and then once I got there it was
kind of like I don't have a man I don't
kids what am i doing
but the question wasn't like what do you
think about what's not don't make me
agree with you mr. TED talks if you do
what do you think about material
possessions now like true but in the
past I've had that so I fulfilled my
childhood dreams now I'm good these are
the same questions that's before oh yes
not in person
I don't know I think I've I think a lot
of times it just makes me sad for other
people that the point I'm about to make
is that people look at me and they're
like oh he doesn't have any problems
because he has money people jet so many
people share the idea that if money
solves all your problems and I know I
talk about this a lot and every time
everyone gets mad at me I just feel bad
for people that I have bad mindset
because I know for a fact it isn't true
stop thinking money solves all your
problems because it just doesn't it
doesn't sometimes I look back on the pad
times when I was just starting off
YouTube and I was just making enough to
pay my rent
each month and that's the kind of time I
look look at almost back as the most
happiest when me and my dad were in
Sweden we we didn't have a lot of money
it wasn't like easy but we were equally
happy then the amount of Fame and
success that I got it was it has been a
huge package and obviously you know
money
I just I prefer to have it obviously but
okay we got some split 93% agree live in
a world where social media is extremely
prevalent so like being on youtuber or
Instagram or social media a lot of it's
like perceived you know you are
constantly getting like quote-unquote
judged but even on social media it
really just depends what you post if
that's very much just to control them
just for social media like I an even if
you ask me what time it is I check my
iPhone I don't even know if this thing
works but like when you're trying to
grow your business especially for me
like in stock trading why do you get
into stock trading is it fun no it sucks
but you can make money so for social
media and you kind of have to show it
but even with social media I mean if you
have a million subscribers on YouTube I
think you're rich yeah because I know
YouTube is writing you a check
oh so you judge people know something's
keeping your lights on now I'm not
judging in a bad way of course you know
I I work every day to try to make videos
too but in the same sense like we judge
people that ask us for money let's see
the Normie filter all normies will say
yes here's the thing obviously money can
buy happiness you can buy you things
that you like it can buy you good health
you can buy a lot of things obviously
obvious
I'm just saying true happiness comes
from here I strongly believe that
it's kind of like that poor broker
mentality it's like you trick yourself
to think that you're happy you trick
yourself that you want these things so
that's why they say yes I guarantee it
all over again like if you're rich and
you're like in a domestic violence
relationship we all love the idea then
and it's even what I touched on before
we like everyone loves the idea that
only if you know only if I was rich then
all my promises it's like a fantasy that
people like to play with it's like the
lottery huh you can buy that idea
literally that's what that is you buy
the mindset oh ah what would I do with
this money you know oh all these things
and you have statistics and actual
studies showing that people that win the
lottery end up more miserable because
their whole life got changed and in a
lot of ways my life got changed
completely due to YouTube and not I
would say always positive like you're
not happy even though you might have
money but still money can buy fun things
and looking back like you're proud of
your accomplishments you're proud of the
journey that you took to get to where
you are and in a way it can pass money
allows you to buy freedom and then
freedom gets you the ability to have
more time to find what makes you happy
it's not a direct result but it could be
like let's say your mom or your dad or
somebody that had a severe illness you
know was in the hospital and they had X
amount of time to live now this person
makes you extremely happy and it's gonna
cost a million dollars or two million
dollars for this surgery that they save
them to survive and you save them like
you quite literally just bought
happiness now that's not to say that it
buys happiness in every area of life
like I can but in certain areas like
yeah money definitely can buy a my most
fulfilling asset is the house that I
bought my parents since I am so grateful
to be able to you were serving another
person hundred percent exactly happy
here's what this guy is gonna say we all
find that I guess reason at different
points in our life so I'm I don't care
you're boring seriously I don't hear the
same people telling us so annoying what
did she say I I didn't not a single word
and it really just depends on your
definition of happiness what makes you
happy and we all find that I guess no no
no there's no your definition of
happiness that is not exist these in at
different points in our life some people
figure it out really early on and some
people it takes them all a lifetime to
find out what's what makes them happy so
even though you could have a lot of
money if you don't know guys if you want
to be rich subscribe and become floor
gang today it that's how it works
instantly I gotta say though people that
aren't rich they love to sell their idea
kind of what I touched on before it's
like the lottery let's sell this idea
that you can become rich too when in
reality a lot of it just comes down to
to pure luck and it did for me
especially with timing I think that's
probably my most humbling thing is that
we know what if I started YouTube now
would have been some as successful no I
don't think so obviously you still have
to put in the hours and I think a lot of
people judge people that are successful
too and basically looking at them back
oh if I put up the same amount of hours
to work I would do it too and that's not
really the case either but right rich
people love to sell this idea to people
too so they can feel like they have some
sort of control over their life like
okay you know there's so many
autobiographies of rich people or or
online programs you know the Jake Paul
program you can be rich too right if I
wake up every morning and if I meditate
and if I could do a jog and if I have
these same routine as these successful
people have then it will happen to you
too as well but it's just selling the
idea that you're in control of your
destiny when unfortunately you're not
the thing is if you're happy then you
don't need to be rich and being rich
will not make you happy something to
think about gently hit the like button
if you enjoyed this video very low-key
very chill very absolute garbage quality
I apologize and I see you guys tomorrow
it up in a world where science knows
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes
[Music]
Bengston are extinct meet my enactors a
sestos who collects ancient items
rediscover your favorite scientifically
accurate dinos what will you create
you